And today we're going to build style
transfer using just tensorflow.
Nothing else. So let's
answer some questions. Five
minutes, five minute Q and a.
And then we're going to get
started. I need myself. All right,
who's in this chat room right now?
All right,
well we got Dan Shiffman and here from
the coating train we got Fernando,
we've got some cool people in here right
now. We've got some celebrities, guys,
we've got some celebrities in here.
So Lao who did up Chez Jack,
I everybody. Wow. Dan was
actually the first one in here.
I'm honored Dan to see you here. Uh, we,
we watch each other's
livestreams occasionally get,
get inspiration high from Germany.
We've got a bunch of people here.
So let me answer some questions.
Hello from Moscow.
Okay,
we are going to do the math
behind style transfer guides.
It's going to be awesome and we're going
to really understand exactly what's
happening under the hood.
No care os it's gonna be awesome.
So check out the link in the description
to fall along with my notes. Usually,
I wouldn't, you know, show that,
but I'm going to show it right now.
Hello from the Netherlands.
Parvez Arvind.
I'll say three more names and then we're
good to go. Lunchtime is perfect timing,
isn't it? Uh, Drma a Sam
and then one more name.
We'll guerrea a buggy out from Stockholm,
Sweden and of course all
these other people. Okay.
So give me up with those questions guys.
Cause I'm so excited to
actually build this thing. Okay.
Because I've been looking at my notes
and trying to figure out exactly how to
explain it so it's gonna be
awesome. Uh, we got Granada. Okay.
Questions your way.
Okay.
Hit me up. What your best questions
as they say. As I say right now,
hello from Israel.
Is tensorflow flow a good library
for a deep learning beginner? Yes,
because it has the most documentation.
It's got the most headway in terms of
all the other deep learning libraries.
There's so much content creating created
around tensorflow, not even just me,
like other people that yes, I think it's
the best way to get started and it's,
it's right now, right now it's the
industry standard and see how that,
what happens in the future.
What is the meaning of style transfer?
Style transfer means it's
we frame adding a filter,
you know, it's like filters,
right? Instagram filters.
But we framed this as an
optimization problem. Okay.
In machine learning we try to frame
everything that's an optimization problem
where we minimize a loss function.
So style transfer is an optimization
problem where we have two images,
we have a styled image,
which slate say have Dan go painting and
then an image of say whatever we want
like yourself.
And we're trying to minimize
the difference between
these two images. Images.
That's the transfer. We're transferring
the style of this van Gogh painting,
all the textures and the waviness
and the colors onto this, uh,
post painting that or this host image.
And we're going to figure out how to do
this. Mathematically. It's not magic.
We know to do it. All of it.
Okay. What is zero shot learning.
We're going to talk about zero shot, one
shot learning at the end of this course.
It's not the bleeding edge of everything.
I can't wait to get started with that,
but it means, but it means a machine
learning with very little data.
And that I believe is the future of
all machine learning. By the way.
There's so much cool shit coming
out right now out of deep mines,
my homie Oreo and yells it.
They had this new paper that
basically beat deep queue,
which has their own algorithm that we're
like cause because Google to buy now
with this new model called
hierarchical reinforcement learning.
So we're starting to see a convergence,
no pun intended between different machine
learning ideologies like this idea of
abstraction between layers and uh,
the idea of reinforcement
and then combining them
together. And then this just,
they, they, they were able
to, uh, beat Pong in like 10
minutes. It was awesome. Okay.
Uh, let me answer three more
questions before we get started.
How transformative it can be
done using tfs tensor flow.
We're going to use transfer
learning right now.
So I'll answer your question as we code.
Would this also work with writing styles?
I actually have a video on that called
build an AI writer. Yes, absolutely.
And I'm going to make another video
on that literally next week. Uh,
can you, can we make a program that
extract knowledge from story? Absolutely.
Um, text summarization. I will have video
on that later on in this course. So Raj,
answer my question. If the network
is possible to use it in trading,
we're not going to use a
convolutional net and trading.
We're going to use a recurring net
and training and we're going to,
and I made a video on that. Not
this one. This one won't be,
where's your girlfriend? No girlfriend.
I'm single and happy being single.
I have too much to do today. Uh, I'm
happy being single. I am a beginner.
Go more detailed. I will go
so detailed. Siddhartha. Don't
even don't even trip. So,
Rod, can you recommend ml forum please?
Uh, the comments section of all my videos,
we are essentially a community guys.
Essentially we are a community
of 75,000 strong engineers.
Everyone from middle school students
who are just getting started learning
Algebra two PhDs at Google,
pushing real research.
So we are a very large community and the
culture we set up is such that if you
ask a question you will get it answered.
Okay.
So we build on Google inception
for this task. Yes, you can.
We're going to use a different
model called a DGG 16 model.
Okay. So one more question and then
we're going to get started with this.
What is the best area to focus
in AI? Uh, so deep learning,
but specifically a focus.
I mean, you know, focusing,
be taken a lot of different ways. Focus
for research, focus for production,
focus for beginner, uh, focus means just a
focus on,
okay.
Uh, I mean, I mean there's so
many things you can focus on,
but I would say it's
such a generic question,
a generative adversarial networks because
those are the coolest things right now
to me. Uh, all right, so that's
it for the questions. Uh,
and so now we're going to get started with
this. So we're going to today a combo.
We're going to build a style transfer
and it's not that we're going to build a
convolutional net from scratch.
We already have that.
We're going to chop off the top layer
and then we're going to add our own layer
on top of that to do, install a fence for
it. So let's just get started with this.
I will explain things as
we go and remember the code
is in the description all
along with me. It's going to
be awesome. Focus. Here we go.
Okay.
All right.
Okay,
so let's see.
Hmm,
let's get started with this.
Okay,
so what I'm gonna do is I'm
not going to code the parts,
the parts that are not machine learning.
I'm only going to code
the machine learning part.
So what we're going to do today is
we're going to perform style transfer.
So let's look at this image for a
second and let's go to this link.
It's just a paper of a bunch of style
transfer images and it's just a way of
describing what we're doing here.
So the first paper that did this,
I talked about this in the weekly video
was, oh, let me show myself as well,
was the uh, [inaudible] paper, right?
A neural algorithm for artistic style.
That was much low Anton.
That was the first paper
that did this. Okay. And we,
and since then there've been quite a few
papers that have built on top of that,
right? So the first one
just transferred to style,
which is what we're going to do today.
We want to transfer the style today.
But there were subsequent papers that
built on that idea. They did it for video,
for example.
And what they found when doing it for
video was that there was actually a lot of
choppiness because think of it,
a video is just a collection
of images and we want to,
and what happened was there was a
lot of choppiness between frames.
So what they did in the next paper,
it wasn't the same group,
it was a different group, but for
video style transfer was they added a,
another loss function called optical
flow based loss. So in minimize,
not just three or two loss functions. They
minimize three or four loss functions.
So they're just changing
these laws functions together.
And what happened was this beautiful
video that we can see here, you know,
like it's, it's very, you know,
you can just think about all the
potential this just happened last year.
So just think about all the
potential it has for artists,
for Arthur to creative things.
And snapchat now has a real time filters.
So this doesn't even take training. You
can just do this in real time. Okay.
So we've seen a lot of progress
starting from that initial paper.
And so what we're going to do is
we're going to, uh, build style,
transferred the original way,
the way that the original paper was done,
and then we'll talk about all
the ways of improving that.
So let's just go down to this image
and take a look at this image, right?
Because these are the, these are the
two images that we are using right now.
And let's talk about the
process of what we're doing.
We're going to slice off that
top because originally the, okay,
so the network we originally
used was called BGG 16. Right?
This was an image classification,
convolutional network, right?
So at each layer it would imply a
series of operations to our input image.
So we can think of our input
image as a matrix of values.
It's a matrix of value,
right?
I'll pixel values and we apply a series
of operations to that image because at
each layer,
at each convolutional layer,
we have what are called
a stack of filters.
And these filters are learned over time.
And so for Bgg 16,
they trained it on thousands of images.
So it's already got a bunch
of filters at each layer.
And at what's happening on each of
these filters is it is multiplying those
filter values by the
input image. Okay. And
video is glitching lot skipping a
lot of brains. Okay, thanks for that.
Let me just remove myself.
That's going to help.
All right.
And so readings from Hong Kong.
Okay. So hopefully that helps. Okay.
And let me know if this is
still glitching. Alright,
close up. This other friend,
just practicum minimal. Okay. So, uh,
we're going to it. Uh, so
that's what we're going to do.
And so this is the BGG 16 layer.
Okay.
And so the idea here is that
let's, let's, let's also look at,
uh, this, this image right
here that's helping, right?
Okay.
So let's take a look at
this. So let, let me,
let me explain what's happening here
for a second. So this is a great,
great image right here. So we want the
contour lines from the content image.
So we want all those lines
from the content image and
we want the textures from
the style image. Okay? Those are
the two different things we want.
And the way we're going to do that
is we're going to add each layer.
There are a collection of filters.
So what are, what are these filters?
Thanks Allen. What are these filters?
These filters are three d, uh, vectors.
So why are they three d? While they are
today, there are a collection of matrices,
right? But there are three d
because of the, the third, uh,
the third dimension is, it's, it's
that RGB and it's a collection of them.
So we've got like say however many filters
we wanted to find, the more filters,
the more accurate our, uh, if we
were willing to do classification,
it's going to be, and these are the
filters that we're going to use.
And so what happens is at
each convolutional filter,
we weren't to perform eight matrix
multiplication and then a summation
operations.
And if there,
if it detects if it detects the feature
and the result is going to be a very
large number, but if it doesn't detect
the feature is going to be zero.
And so we can think of these filters
at feature identifiers. Okay.
They're identifying certain features.
And so what we're going to do for,
for this or this is we're
going to perform, um,
we're going to minimize the loss between
the labeled image and the feature. Uh,
so what happened actually,
what BGG was initially set out to do was
he was initially set out to minimize a
loss between a label image and a future
map output. So at each of these layers,
after all of these operations,
it's once an outmoded output what's
called a feature map or an activation map.
It's the same thing, which is just
a huge matrix of values. Okay?
And we want to minimize the difference
between what that feature map is and then
what our content is. Okay? So
that's what we're gonna do here.
And um, so those are
our two images, right?
We have a content image that's going to
be whatever we want to modify and then a
style image,
which is going to be whenever style that
we think is cool that we want to apply
to this content image. Lastly,
we have this mixed image,
which is going to be just an empty random
noise initialized matrix that we're
going to add to over time.
Okay?
We're going to use what kind of
compute two different style or uh,
loss functions.
We're going to do the style loss and
we're going to do the content loss.
And then we're going to
combine those loss functions.
use a gradient value,
which we're going to talk about
to update this mixed image. Okay?
So that's the high level overview of
what this, what's going to happen.
And after a hundred to a
thousand iterations, this
image is going to be mixed.
Okay? So that's what the high
level is of what this is. Okay?
So we're going to start off by
importing our for dependencies.
Map all live is going to help us plot
out what we see tensorflow is our machine
learning library num Pi is going to help
us calculate what's called the Graham
Matrix that we're going to do.
I'm going to talk about later all on.
And then Pila images is going to show
the image that we want to show. Okay?
I'm now using tensorflow version a
one and everybody else should as well.
They have updated it. And
the other thing is, uh, uh,
I'm using python three so everybody
should update to python three. Yes,
I finally updated to python three. Okay.
And it's really easy to update. Just,
you know, Google Update Python Three
Jupiter notebook. It's just, um, you know,
you could do it in two or three lines,
a command lines with Anaconda.
So the first thing we're
going to do is import BGG 16.
This is a 16 layer convolutional
neural network. Okay.
This was pretrained.
Okay.
So this network already
has all of those filters.
They're already has all of those filters
and we want to use these filters as
tools to help us perform style transfer.
Okay.
So that's the first step is important.
Bgg 16 and never going to download it.
And so I'm already downloaded it.
It's a big file,
half a Gig and it's probably
going to take, you know,
depending on your bandwidth,
anywhere from 10 minutes to an
hour to download this thing.
But once you download it,
you're good to go because everything
else is going to be local. Okay.
So now the next step is to define
our image helper functions.
So we've got three of these and you
know, they're, they're very, you know,
standard load, load the image, save
the image and plot the image. Okay.
And it's using non Pi to do
these three, uh, functions.
So these are just standard functions
and I'll talk about these later on,
but right now, just know that there to an
image, save an image and plot an image.
Okay? So we haven't done any
machine learning yet. Uh,
these are just, you know,
standard image help her function. So now
let's get to the machine learning. Okay?
So what we're going to do right now
is we are going to define our loss
functions. Okay? So before
we define our loss function,
we want you to find
the mean squared error.
So let me just type this out and I'm
going to talk about what is the mean
squared error.
Okay?
So the mean squared error is a function
given input tensors so are in presenters.
In this case we're going to be called
A and B and I'll talk about what these
templates are,
but it's just one line of code.
And the one line is going to be 10
truckloads reduce mean function.
And then it's going to,
we're going to take the square value
of the difference between both of these
tenters. That's it. Okay. So, and
then I'll, I'll compile that. Okay.
So what is happening here?
So the mean squared error
is the average of two,
uh, is the, is the, is
the difference between,
it's the average of the square of the
difference between both the output feature
map and the image that we're
going to the army put him in.
So let's look at what's happening
here. Okay. So it was called, um,
BGG 16, because there's 16
layers and uh, you know,
more layers mean generally
better predictions,
but less layers mean less computation
times. So it's a trade off.
It's up for mean squared error.
We're taking two input tents.
So one of these tents, hers is
going to be our image. Okay. Uh,
either our content they made or our
style image and we're going to use it for
both and the other tents or is going
to be the, uh, the feature map. Okay.
The result of the, uh,
whenever layer that we choose.
And so what we're gonna do is we're
going to subtract the difference.
So these are two matrices, okay. And
we're going to subtract the difference,
the square of the, okay. And
then we're going to square that.
And then we're going to do reduce means.
So what is reducing meat? Okay, so right.
So this just this value right here.
Do you have thoughts?
Square of the difference between these
two tensors is going to be a matrix
valley. And then we want to reduce the
mean. So what did that mean? So we,
if we have a matrix to reduce the mean,
so it would just be like this.
We're going to find the average of all
of those values inside of that Matrix.
So for this, a two dimensional, uh,
this matrix right here, one, one, two,
two,
okay?
It's going to be a 1.5. So that's the
average value of this whole major.
So this is going to output a scaler
which is a single value, okay?
That's what means where an error is
doing, okay? And it's a weight. And, and,
and the reason we square it so
that it's positive. Okay? Uh,
we went to a positive value. Oh, okay.
So that's what we're going to use as a,
as a helper function inside of our
content laws and our style loss. Okay?
So the first thing we're going to do
is write out a function for our content
loss.
Okay.
So we're going to call it create content
loss and inside of it we're going to
use that, uh, mean squared error
function. All right, thanks Erez.
Um, so our parameters for this,
we're going to be session.
Okay. So our are session,
the model we're going to
use, I need to relax. Okay.
I'm trying to talk slower
and he's lied sections.
So let me do that because at one point
I'm height and the other point I want to
be as clear and communicative
as possible so I will slow down.
I'm really trying to improve
the speed of my speech.
I've gotten a lot of great feedback on
that and I'm very open to more feedback.
So the parameters for this content laws
are going to be the tensorflow session,
the model, which is DGG 16, the
content image, and then the layer ids,
which are the indices for which layers
we want to use to get those output
feature maps. And these are the, the,
the layers that we have decided to
use for optimizing for content loss.
And these are going to be the
higher level layers. Okay.
Because those higher level layers in
a convolutional nets are akin to the
content,
right?
These are the big high level objects
that are inside of an image or like,
you know, for a van Gogh it would be the
moon and the houses, things like that.
And the lower levels are the texture
or the contours, like the lungs,
quantum may, I actually increases the
speed of my videos. Interesting. Okay,
well you're in the minority. Okay.
But maybe, I don't even know.
It'd be cool to get some data.
Maybe I can do a boat back to this.
So the first thing we're going to do
is once you've define HP dictionary,
now a Phoenix and is a python
dictionary object that's generated with
placeholders as Keith's.
This essentially is going to generate
a set of placeholder values. Okay.
And in a place holders are
going to be your image, right?
So that's it.
So what this did is it generated a team.
Now you care where the key was, the image
and the value was the content image.
So we do this every time we want to feed
anything into arc computation graph,
we feed it in as a dictionary,
okay? So that was the first step.
And then the next step we're going to
do is we're going to define what our
layers are.
Now we have our model that we defined
as our parameter and then we're going to
get those cancers, uh, by
defining those layer ideas. Okay?
So we can play around with what indices
we want to use for our layer ids and the
researchers in this paper did as well.
You're going to get different results
from different layers that you use, okay?
And this is not to say that these are
the best and disease, but they are,
there are a set of indices that do give
us good results. And abstracting this, uh,
question even further, what
defines beauty? Can we,
can we frame beauty in and of
itself as an optimization problem?
This is something to
think about in the future.
How can we minimize a loss for beauty?
Beauty is so subjective, but can,
can it be objective? So something to
blow your mind a little bit. Uh, okay,
so those are layers.
So the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to calculate our values.
So these are the output values
when we've run our session,
given the layers that we've just helped
calculated and we beat it in our feet
dictionary. Okay. Okay.
So what this is going to do is it's
going to get me a output values for those
layers, for the, for the content image.
Okay? So the next step is we're going to
okay.
Say, okay, so we're going to
run the model graph now. Okay.
So for the model graph,
we're going to say as defaults.
All right?
See how many,
okay.
Excellent. Monograph as
default. And uh, okay.
So now what we're going to do is
we're going to initialize our losses.
So this is setting, so we can, so we're
going to add computational notes to it.
And uh,
that's what we're going to do right now.
So let's first define our
losses because we're active.
Then I calculate a collection of
losses and utilize an empty list. Okay?
We'll call it layer, uh, losses.
That's the name of our list. And
the next step is we're going to move
down a little bit. We're gonna say, okay,
so for each layer that we have for valued,
for each layer that we have,
what we you iterate through those layers
that we get fined in those indices.
Okay? Uh, values layers,
okay?
Okay.
That's where they start contributing to
AI is to just start pushing code to get
hub that you, that you find
fun and documenting it really
well. And then, you know,
marketing, like posting it to
people and sharing it with people.
We're all sharing,
you know,
the line between research
and production is quite thin.
Everything is really a discovery
in and up in, in any, in any way,
even as simple hyper parameter change.
Uh,
since you can result in an
incredible discovery, uh, personal,
their link is in the description.
Okay?
So what we're doing is for every layer
we are iterating through every single
layer. Right now we're waiting to get
that value. Okay? So what does that value?
We're going to define it as a TF
constant with comedic 10, not change.
And this is once you, uh, BB,
uh, content, images value. Okay.
So then what we're going to do now is open
to calculate that loss. Okay, now lost.
And now this is where we use that mean
squared error that we defined earlier.
And we're gonna use it to the two in
pretenses are going to be the value add a
layer and then the constant
value. So this is the, the book,
the content image and then the, the,
the set of features at a layer. Amber,
what you minimize that loss. The
basketball for deep learning is, um,
the deep learning book by
Ian Goodfellow. Okay? Uh, no.
The one by Yoshua Bengio search
Giyasova Nto learning such a great book,
especially for the mass loss
amines. Right? Air. Okay.
So now we're going to say,
okay,
so these are all of our losses that were
calculated and we'll get to append it
to that list,
that empty Lou when to do it,
right?
More Games. And I'm a full on game
AI next. So we'll see how that goes.
I think it'll be very,
very popular.
So once we have all of
those loss functions,
like be a good average value,
you think that's reduced mean function.
Okay?
So these are our layers losses and
that's after we're done with everything.
Okay? And then, uh,
we're going to say, okay,
so at the end of this we're
going to return the total loss.
So what this is going to do is this is
going to give us a total loss value.
And let's talk about what we
just did. We said, okay, uh,
we're going to get the mean squared or
of the teacher had to be in the given
layers in the model. So between the
content image and the mixed image.
And so when this is minimized, it's
going to, when we minimize this,
it's going to make them mixed image
that much more stylized. Okay? So this,
this defines our content boss. So ideally
we can do the live style loss as well,
right? We just take both up, feature the
feature maps from a layer and then the,
uh, you know, the, the
image, uh, where whether the,
the style image of the content image and
we just calculate the mean square error
between them and we minimize
that. But we cannot, uh,
previous line from the last either a typo.
Thank you. But we cannot do that. Okay.
So we cannot do that because,
uh,
for whatever reason, wow. That actually
compile without any errors because w okay.
So let's, let's actually answer
this, why we can't talk about,
okay.
Right. Total loss. Thank you Allen.
So, so we don't do that for style.
For style. We add eight, another step
called the gram matrix and let's,
let's really talk about
what is happening here.
So the reason we use a gram
matrix, so let, let's let,
let me show an image of this, this,
this, this, this will help. So
that's okay. Okay. So this is,
so this is kind of scary looking,
but don't worry about it. A grime
interest. All it is, is we are taking the,
uh, measuring the correlation
between our teacher chant,
like doctors after flattening the
featured filter image into vectors.
So all this is doing is
it's taking, it's, it's,
it's the matrix product between our
initial matrix and then its transpose,
which is just, uh, which is just
flipping at 90 degrees. Essentially.
We're just multiplying a
matrix by its transpose.
That's it multiplying a matrix by its
transpose that is the grand matrix.
Okay. And so that's what
we're doing for that layer.
Okay. And for our style. So for
every uh, style layer that we choose,
we're going to calculate a gram matrix.
And that Graham Matrix is what we're
going to use to minimize via the mean
squared error. So let's just start
building and then we'll start,
start talking about what exactly is
happening. So for brand matrix function,
we're going to have our input tensor.
Okay.
So you think better of the dot products
for vectors of the feature activity
patients have a style layer.
Okay.
Uh, yeah I did. And it was the equal sign,
right? For the total total loss. Okay.
So the grand major 10,
remember guys we following along and
the get help link that I've linked to in
the district and it's got all my notes.
I'm basically talking through it and,
and coding at the same time.
So this is going to be a for the tensor,
okay. This is going to be a 40 tensor, uh,
at a given layer because we
have the, we have, right?
So it's gonna be the collection
of pixels and then the RGB,
which makes it three d and it's 40,
because we have a collection of those.
So we have several of those.
So we have a collection of broody tensors,
which means it take for the tenser and
that's what the shape is going to be.
And what we want to do for our style
layers is we're going to calculate our,
uh,
brand matrix hello up Doula. So now we're
going to say, let's get those channels.
Okay. So channels are just even
those. So if you think of, uh,
the outputs of each layer,
so an output of each layer is going to be,
let's see what our history was.
CDS,
like stacks of layers.
Each of these stacks is a matrix
and we call those our channels.
Each of these is is one of our channels.
Okay.
So it's the word activation and
feature as it's used similarly.
So feature map activation
happens, same thing. Okay,
so back our number of channels.
Where we want to do is we want
to define these channels and
we're going to get the number of Eagle
Peter Channels for the input tensor,
which is assumed to be a convolutional
layer with four dimensions. Okay. And then
we're going to say, let's get the
matrix, which is going to be the,
let's talk about what this matrix
and this matrix is going to be.
We have a shape, it's going to be
negative one. And then number of council,
what did we just do here?
So
hang on one means whatever
number makes this state of fit.
That's why we put negative one in here.
But what we're doing is
we're reshaping the tensor.
So it is a two dimensional matrix.
So it basically just a flattens the
contents of each of the feature channels.
That's what the,
it's flattening the contents of each
of the feature channels so that we can
multiply it, uh, in a second through ts
matrix multiplication function. We are,
we are making it, it's a kin
to normalization. Okay. It's,
we're taking both of these values
between art style, uh, and our, uh,
mixed image and we are normalizing it.
You think this reshape function such
so that we can multiply it in a second.
Okay. So let's get back
Graham Matrix now. Okay.
So we're going to use 10 truckloads
matrix multiplication function to do this
and we've got this great
transpose function.
So we're going to remember it's a grand
matrix and just a matrix multiplied by
its transpose. So the same matrix will
multiply by its transpose and then
okay,
okay.
So there transposed
by the Matrix and remove it's
comma cause we don't need it.
And then that's going to be art remix
and then we can return that. Okay.
Uh, so it style transfer is an extension
of a convolutional nets. Uh, it has uh,
Ganzer a whole different ballgame.
There are a whole different ballgame and
we're going to talk about that later.
But before we understand how gangs work,
we have to understand how a transfer
learning works and how convolutional nets
really work. And that's the goal of this.
Okay? So that's it for our grand matrix.
So that is the extra step we add
freestyle loss. Okay. So let's see.
Let's actually compute style loss.
All right?
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
compute soloff's now given that Graham
Matrix function that we used earlier.
So the input to this are going to be the
same basic format that like we did for
the content lots, except we're
using a solid image as our input,
not at content image, right? And
we're adding this extra step,
which is Graham maker steps.
So we'll talk about what this looks like
when we get to it, but we're feeding in,
remember the dictionary and it's
creates placeholders for our, uh,
feed dicks and
okay,
went to, and this is going to create a
placeholder value for our style image.
And then the next step is to get the
layers to our layers are going to be
whatever we got from our layer id.
So whatever we defined and we defined
these earlier or we will define these
layer ids,
right?
These are essentially a can to hyper
parameters for this or this particular
optimization problem because as we tune
these are the results will be different,
right?
So,
okay,
because there are layers. So now we're
going to define our model. Okay. So it's,
you know, very similar. We're going
to define our model as defaults and
okay,
so we're going to define our gram layer.
So this is where our,
this is the line that is difference
comparatively compared to the content,
uh, Blas. This style loss means we
have to take the grand maple scenes.
That is a difference here. We're taking
the grant-maker seeds of each layer.
We're not just saying here's the raw
layer of value, which is just that matrix.
We're saying get the gram matrix on
that layer. So, and also, you know, to,
to give some backup to this gets,
he's the guy who initially made this when
asked why the grand matrix in a talk,
he said the grant Matrix and codes,
second order statistics
of the set of filters. Oh,
I'll talk about the noise
and get a second Javier.
But basically it's looking
at it from a higher level.
So it sort of mushes all the
features at a given layer,
tossing spatial information aside in
favor of a measure of how different
teachers are correlated.
So by, so Graham mates,
your seats essentially or like it toss
away everything that's unnecessary just
to focus on this style. And,
and this works for style,
but not for content. It's lower layer. And
I'm sure there's more theory why
reading the Grand Matrix, but, uh,
that's the best I could get out
of Getty's. Um, and you know,
it's better than just
saying it just works. Right.
Which is a lot of machine learning.
Uh, right. So, so that's the grim, uh,
layers. And then we have,
where were we again?
So I went up for a second and go
back down. Okay. So where were we?
We were rights here.
So we said that we're taking our grand
layers and we were feeding an art
dictionary.
So for feeding at that dictionary
that we just defined edict,
and we're saying that,
uh,
we're going to define
our layers, losses. So
I'll just say now we're defining that
MP a list that we're going to add all of
our layer losses too,
right? So, so that's that.
Those are our two lines before we get
started with our iteration periods.
So for our iteration period, what we're
going to do is we're going to say, okay,
so for all of those brand makeup seats,
at each layer,
we're going to compute the loss
function so that we can minimize it.
And so we're happy. We have to, um, input
here the value, which is a marketing edge,
and then the grand layer,
which is the grand later. Okay?
So the value is going to be
constant because it's a TF dot.
Con because we don't want
it to change, right? We,
it's not a variable because
we don't want it to change.
It's going to stay the same. And, uh,
now we're going to just talk to the loss
to loss is going to be the mean squared
error between,
and now this is the important part.
The important part is we're calculating
the mean square error of the Graham
layer and then the value constants.
So this is between the grant matrix and
the value of a brand mantra matrix when
inputting a style image. Okay? So
that's between each of the layers and
the input style image layer. Okay?
So then once we have all of those losses,
we're going to add them all
to our wrist style list.
So layer equal layer the losses
at each layer. So you know,
we're combining these losses and we
later combine the combination of those
losses between, right? So it's like
combining and then combining again we'll,
we'll talk about the
second step of combining.
But this is the first step of Kumbaya.
We're combining losses for a
style of and for content. Okay,
so we're appending whatever we calculated
at each iteration here. And then
now we're going to calculate
the total loss with total loss.
Total loss is going to be the
going to reduce the mean
queen
players so that we're going to take the
average of all of those losses. Remember,
there's just takes the average of every
single number that we have in our matrix
and then we're going to return that
value. Okay. And that's our style, floss.
And we get, and this is a scalar value,
it's a, it's a single number. Okay.
The scalar about him.
So that's our style loss.
And then what do we got here? We've
got some invalid syntax. My favorite,
my favorites.
Okay.
Alright. Comma. Yeah. Okay.
So that's what we did for that.
And uh,
right. So feed dick, model dot
creates. Okay. Model dots. Create.
See dicked.
Yeah.
Image style. Image. Uh, what is it
saying here? Oh, brand made friends.
So for Graham Matrix Graham
layers, we have, see Dick,
where was I? So many things to keep track
of your Oh, right. That was what it was.
It's okay. So, um,
okay,
let's see. Oh, right, yeah.
Great.
Brand Matrix layers and then edict
or where we do our majors layers,
four layers.
Oh,
right.
Let's see. Hold on. I had a lot of
code here that I'm looking at him.
Hold on a second.
So Graham layers are going
to be the gram matrix layers,
four layers in theirs.
Oh,
so what's actually, there's an extra
line here that I forgot about. So
not about certain line
here.
Hold on. There's a certain
line that I'm missing here. Ah,
okay.
I'm just remove these right here.
Great. So now, so there's actually one
more loss. I lied. There's one more loss,
but I lied because it's
very, very trivial. And we
used, it was using the paper,
but it's, it's not, you know,
it's very trivial and it's,
it just starts to confuse if we,
if we talk about it at the start,
but we're going to talk about it now.
So this is just,
this is the de noising loss. And so
what happened was when, when they,
when they didn't do this last one,
they just computed the style and
the content was, the image was okay,
but when they added this denoising loss,
which we can also call
the total variation loss,
it's also called that what happened
was the results improved. So,
okay.
What it does is it calculates
the difference between the,
so it shifts the input image by
one pixel on the x and y axis.
And then it calculates a difference
between the shifted image and the original
image. And so the absolute, and we,
and we use the absolute value to make it
positive. Okay. So let's talk about this.
So this is the one more lost
than to never going to add.
Very pretty a lot function. It's going
to be, you know, two lines of code,
but a necessary to just know
slightly improve our results.
And you know,
there could be even more lock function
that we can think about and um, great.
So there are 16 layers here.
Okay.
Or is the absolute
value, um, for this and,
okay.
Uh, in fact I can just,
you know, I'm just going to
paste this in here because we're going
to get right to the meat of the code.
Now just talk about it since it's
just two lines. It's got a lot of, uh,
medical things here. So we are, we are,
what we're doing here is we are, uh,
taking the absolute value to make
this a positive value, right?
And we're going to calculate the sum of
the pixels in these images and basically
it can help suppress noise in the mixed
images that were generating. Okay? So
we'll calculate the sum of the pixel
values between the shifted image and our
original adage and the variation.
And the variation is referring
to that shifted image.
And the original image is it removes
the noise and the noise is like the
blurriness. It's not that clear.
And by shifting it in my, you know,
minimizing it, we're kind of like
recreating this blurriness and we're,
we're saying,
you know,
we could even shift it more than
one pixel line and try that.
They didn't try that, you know, shifting,
you know, we could do other, um, you know,
artificial noising step, like,
what can we do to like, you know,
mess up this image in whatever way.
Okay.
And then we're going to
optimize for minimizing that
so that our actual value is
smaller. Okay. So,
so now what we're going to do is, um,
how has the, how has the frame rate,
by the way guys,
I definitely tell me in the comments
how you feel about the frame rates. Um,
I'm trying to improve my
life live streams. Okay.
So now we're going to get to the good
stuff. This is the mean of the code.
This is where it all comes together
to style transfer algorithms.
This is where we build our model and
we're going to use the loss on that.
We calculated,
okay,
so let's talk about what these
parameters are going to be.
So the creditors are going to be uh,
uh,
the text is blurred. Pretty cool frame
rate. Thanks sir. Okay, framer seems good.
All right, cool. So how much,
so how much do we want to weigh these
loss functions is a good question. Okay,
so you don't like this. This can be
played with, right? So what they did,
so you can see here that the weight style,
the wait for the style is going to be
10. And so it's almost, you know, it's,
it's like eight times more than
the weight for the content.
And we can modify these
weights so that we can,
we've got 1:44 PM over there.
Okay. Um, very the text,
I'll make this bigger. Yeah. Seven
20 Pete by C bomb. Okay. Interesting.
So we've got all over
the place. Um, okay. So,
so we're weighing this style way
more than we're rang the content.
And it doesn't mean that these
are the best weights and in fact,
we can have learning out rhythms for
learning the best ways we could learn the
best weeks later. Right? So that's that.
Those are the weights
that we're going to use.
And we're going to define these weights,
uh, here in a second, but right.
So let's go ahead and just
do our first cap. Like,
assuming that everything else we did
was just a helper function for this.
This is the real deal. So we're
first going to define model. Okay.
It's gonna be easy. 16. We imported
it. We're good to go. Right? 16 layer,
convolutional net, fully connected layer.
At the end, it's thinking like, oh,
I'm going to be used for classification.
That what is thinking right now? Okay, so
now we're going, but it doesn't know
any better. He doesn't know any better.
We're not going to use
it for classification.
We're going to use it for
style transfer itself.
We've got our graph and we're
went to eat in our model. Okay?
So that's the session.
Remember the session always encapsulates
our computation graphs. Okay?
So then we've got these print functions
here that we're going to use to help us
see what's happening.
And I'll just paste these in because
they're really just help her, you know?
So now, now is the, the good stuff.
So cures are lost for our content. We,
our first loss function
and we defined the, um,
we defined find the
lost function, right? So
the session is going to,
we're going to give it the session value,
we're going to get a model value and
we're going to give it a content image and
the layer ids. Okay? So no buffering dot.
Interesting. Okay, good
thing. A good thing. All good
things to consider. Okay. So
once you give it that content,
obviously,
because we are trying to minimize the
loss for the contents and then we're going
to say other layer id. So these
are the indices. So right.
We just feed in those layering
the teas and if went to, uh,
calculate the difference between the raw
activations to after given layers and
our content image. And we think of that
as a matrix, just the rock divisions,
activations, no hidden step and the
value, the value is our last content.
And remember this is eight scalar value.
Okay,
this going to give us a scalar value.
The next step is to calculate our,
our silos.
Okay,
so for our style loss
or is that extra step,
the extra step is going to be
the brand to these calculation.
So it's not that we just give it
those raw activations. We also,
once you give it the,
we take those rocks,
the patients and we calculate the
gram matrices from that. Okay.
And the same thing, but
on the, you know, in this
and this, uh, you know,
function. We're not,
we're not talking about
the grand mason city's,
that's all happening internally because
we could find that on the outside it
looks the same. We're just good
programming, right? We, we,
we want it to look the same because I'm
okay.
There was no reason for us to expose
that grant makers brown matrix or
calculation, uh, externally for, you know,
this, this function for re re usability.
Okay. So that's for our loss
and that's where our style,
and remember we had one more very trivial
loss function for de noising. Right?
So for noising we'd say we just said,
well,
take our model then remember to
the noises so that, you know,
it's just so little less per worried, you
know, a little catch up at the end. Okay.
So those are our three loss functions.
And now what we're going to do,
mmm.
Is we're going to adjust,
be here.
That's a great question.
Why don't we use the gray mates
and sees for content loss. Um, so,
uh, so it's a second order updates.
It's a second order statistic,
meaning for, for stock. So style
is actually, you know, it's, it's,
you can think of style as more abstract
and content content is something we can
point out and say that is
content. Like for example, the,
what is the famous content like the,
the,
the clock that is bending in
the Dolly picture dollies. Um,
Geez, where's my mouse? The
Dolly pick, you know, with the,
with the clock that's bending.
That is, that is content.
That is something we could look at and
we can definitively say that is the
content. So we can take the raw
activation and say, you know,
it's just literally there. It's,
it's, it describes that that object,
but style is much more nuance.
Style is much more embedded and
ingrained throughout every layer.
It's not just like at one way or we see,
oh that is the,
that is where the clock is. It's,
it's embedded in every layer.
So by taking the brand matrix,
we're kind of abstracting that.
We're taking another layer
of abstraction to say
that we want to style is even more
abstract and content. And so Graham major,
she's helped us create that
extra layer of abstraction. Okay.
So now we're going to
create those adjustment weights, right?
So for our content and our style.
So it's basically just the same
thing here. So we'll just, you know,
copy and paste the same thing over
and over again for three lines.
But basically it is creating tentraflow
variables for adjusting the values of
the loss functions. Okay.
So we went to adjust how,
uh,
we want to adjust how,
okay,
how much we want to weight each of them.
Okay.
And so now what we're going to do is
we're going to initialize them, right?
So we're,
we say we're gonna say session not run.
We want to commercialize this value so
isn't the actual run step.
And the next step is we're going to
actually adjust them because we haven't
actually adjusted them. We've just
declined them. Now we actually adjust it.
Now we actually,
uh,
Skoll kinds were,
can definitely be applied to audio and
wavenet is a great application of that.
Um, and there are, you know,
there's a definitely a lot of discoveries
to be made around speeding up wave net.
Okay.
Um,
but the idea of transferring the style
to something can be applied to all forms
of media, not just images, audio, video,
uh, you know, all sorts of things.
But these are updated values.
And the reason we're using this
one e 10 value is because we,
it basically is just taking the
reciprocal values of the loss functions.
And then it's going to,
uh, using this small value,
one e minus 10 is added to avoid
the possibility of division by zero.
So if Los content was equal to zero,
this would just throw an error.
So that's what we add is very small. You
can almost think of it as a bias vector,
but for adjusting, adjusting
these, uh, these, uh, uh,
wait values. Okay. And so now we're
going to actually combine those losses.
So now that we've defined the law,
says we defined how much we want to
weight each of them. Now we finally,
we combine the losses.
One big,
huge rocks function,
and it's a weighted loss function that
we will minimize to generate the mixed
images. And the reason we're
multiplying these loss, uh,
values with the reciprocal adjustment
values that we tabulate it up here is
because we can use the relative weights
for the loss functions that are easier
to select the exact choice and the co the
client later the style and the content
labors. So this is our combined
loss function and Guinea.
And so give it a five minutes and
we're going to get right to the, um,
we're going to get right to the actual
output value. We're almost there guys.
Stick. You guys are very patient
for sticking with us, right?
There's a lot of stuff
we're talking to now.
So now we're going to calculate
the gradients. So let's,
so the gradient is a great
thing to talk about, right?
So we have our combined loss functions
and now we're in these tension built dean
radiant function to get full value of Rep.
It's not just one
you,
uh, we're using multiple gradient values
and we're going to get the combined loss
given our model and could
value and they'll combine loss.
So this is what it's going to
do is going to get the gradient,
the combined lost function
with regard to the input image,
which is the mixed image.
So this,
this wants to minimize difference
between the mixed image and remember that
mixed images, just the blurry, you
know, uh, nothing image, right?
It's initialized random noise image and
that's what we want to output as are
fully know output value
that the transferred style
image and the gradient is
going to get the um,
it's a mathematical function.
So the gradient value is going to
give us a direction. And so, uh,
a great image of this,
I haven't. Great. Um,
I'll talk about building an AI
writer also. I'll do another one.
Uh,
you know,
generates Shakespeare or paintings or
Shakespeare or text check out that is not,
you have to create an that's
Nike and some dude. Um,
what's like that gradient act sigmoid.
Basically,
I'm just trying to visualize
what this looks like,
but basically we are taking the,
sorry. Okay. So we have a
sigmoid function and we,
the gradient is like if
we were to take a line,
I'm just showing this with my mouse
up or down. That's it. Up or down.
We take numbers and do we
want to push these numbers up,
we want to push these numbers down.
And so that's what the gradient is doing.
So when we take these radiant values,
okay,
we take these Brady and values and we
multiply it by weights are the weights in
this case are going to be the image.
It's going to update our image in
a direction which is up or down.
That is going to minimize a loss.
Okay?
So the gradient is a collection of
those gradients for each of those, uh,
feature vectors. Uh, for each of those,
remember it's a, it's a stack of features.
It's a stack of features, okay?
To take the list of 10 search,
radiant was important.
Super important,
pushing numbers up and down so
you didn't get that right. So
these are all collection of scalar values.
Okay?
These are a collection of scalar values.
And when we take these gradients and we,
uh, these are a collection
of scalar values and, um,
we're going to use them, not here, but in
a second. We're going to actually, I'll,
I'll talk about them when we, when
we get to number, basically, uh,
I'll talk about them.
Okay.
So this is going to give us this
list of scalar values. Okay?
That's what greatness is doing
with regard to the loss function.
And we'll talk about what it's doing
with this scalar values in a second.
But just think about it as scalar values.
Right now we're,
we're about to get stem. So now we're
going to initialize that mixed image.
We haven't actually initialize that mixed
image yet. Now we initialize it, right?
So we're using random,
the num pies,
random dot rand function to initialize
an empty matrix of just random values.
Okay? And we're going to update its
image to us through iteration. Okay?
So,
so now it's time for our training staff.
So for every,
so for
number of iterations that we have and
we have quite a bit of iterations to do,
you know, anywhere from a hundred
to thousands. This by the way,
it's going to take like an hour
on my laptop, which is a Mac book,
2016 forced touch bar,
which sucks.
I need a better computer anyway. So, um,
great. So now, so the first step remember,
is going to be to create the
feed dictionary. All right?
So we're going to create their feed
dictionary and then given that mixing the
director, we dress initialize them, makes
an image, create that feed dictionary.
Okay.
Now what we're going to do is we're going
to calculate the value of the gradient
as well as adjusting the dial you,
so
it's breaking up from time
to time. It could just be
you. Okay. Interesting to um,
notes.
So we got a couple minutes left.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to talk about the gradients and so in
order to focus on the gradients
that we're going to do,
paste the rest so that we can focus
on the Greenheck values. Okay. So,
so we have those gradients,
right?
There are a collection of scalar values
between the mixed image and our combined
loss function. So, you
know, think of them as like,
there are the representation of like
the what we want to use to help us,
you know, increase the style
in our, that mixed image. What,
how do we stylize that image to
the gradients are going to give us,
tell us how to update our image.
Okay. A gradient is a slope value.
It's a given, a sigmoid function. So
if it would just,
you remember, so for
you know, fee for next,
we took the derivative a sigmoid
and it gave us a, a line.
A straight line is great. It means
slope. It's just a straight line.
And the line either po points up or
at points down, this is a great image.
Either points up or it points down.
Okay?
Uh, so it's, you know, it could be
plus two or minus two, right? And so,
so when we take these gradients
and we multiply it by that image,
it's going to transfer it. It's going
to update the image in some way.
And every time we, every time we minimize
our loss, the gradients is going to be,
it's going to be better. And by better,
I mean it's going to help us. Uh,
it's going to be,
it's going to minimize the difference
between the output image and our style
image, right? It's gonna every time it's
going to be minimal, minimal. All right?
So eventually when it's zero,
a local minimum, uh, the,
the output image is going to be the most
stylized that it can be for whatever,
uh,
however we frame this problem.
So this step is going to remove the single
dimensional entries from the shape of
an array so that our greatest value is
going to be reduced such that it's going
to be the same size so that we
can multiply it by our matrix.
Okay? So then we're going to
scale the gradient. So what do we,
what are we doing and
why are we doing this?
This is the same thing as learning rates.
So it's the ratio between the weights
and the updates. So if, if, if,
if we don't scale it properly, then it's
not going to converge fast. But if we,
if we don't scale it fast enough,
then it's not going to converge ever.
If we steal it too. No, sorry.
If we scale it too slowly,
then it's never going to convert.
If we scale it too fast,
there's going to overfit so, so we
have to update not just our, um,
gradients,
but our,
our weights at each layer so that
it's going to converge properly.
That's what this step is. And then we're
going to perform in gradient descent.
And so this is the actual
gradient distance part, right?
This is what I'm talking about. We take
those beck gradients, which is a scaler,
and then we multiply it by the scale of
value that we calculated here and it's
going to give us that output mixed image,
which is going to suck.
It's going to suck at it.
It's not gonna look like anything.
But the more we update this gradient,
the more this image is going
to look doper and doper. Okay.
Like more and more stylized. Okay.
And so that's gonna be our mix image.
And then we went to clip all the values
that are not between zero and 255.
So everything more,
we're going to clip it because we
want this to be an art be values.
And then we're going to print out the
number of iterations and we're going to
plot them. Okay? So that's
what that's going to do.
And then we're ready to,
uh,
show you know what we're going to,
so that's that part style
transfer algorithm. Now we
can print out load images.
Not that fine. Yeah, I probably
didn't. Oh, I need to find the load.
It makes function earlier. It's all good.
I didn't compile that earlier. Let's um,
we just show this.
Okay.
So is it actually like if I were
to actually run this right now,
it would take a lot of computation power,
which would lag the hell
out of this livestream.
And I definitely don't want to
lag this slide stream further.
So let me talk about this for two minutes
and we're going to do an ending to a,
okay. So where were we? Okay,
so remember, so Devin d a
style image, the content image.
And then the indices or
whatever we want to use,
like what are the layers we're choosing
for this? And then how much went away.
Each of those loss functions,
it's going to slow, minimize
that loss. So this, this,
even this first iteration is going
to take like, like five minutes.
So even in this first
iteration, you already see
that it's getting better. Like,
like already you went from nothing to
this in one single iteration. Okay.
And after the others, it's just gonna be,
so it's kind of like an ex, uh, um, uh,
negative exponential curve. So, uh, it's,
it's super good at first and then every
subsequent iteration is going to get, uh,
you know, the, the, the, um,
improvement is going to get smaller
and smaller over time. Okay.
Hm.
Okay.
So let me do five minute Q and a to end
and then we're going to get started.
Hi Guys,
I'm definitely going to improve black.
Don.
I really want to improve these livestreams
and I really want to, and I will,
I promise that.
Well,
because I love you guys and want
to make this better for you. Okay.
So ask any leftover questions
you have from this live stream,
which I'm going to read out very clearly,
but the people who are
watching this later. And then
I'm going to ask, you know,
whatever other questions you have as
well about life or Amin machine learning.
So Raj,
what do you think of neuro evolution of
augmenting topologies needs as a genetic
algorithm? And do you think you
will do a video on it? Sometimes.
So genetic algorithms I've done a video
on genetic algorithm is called um,
genetic algorithms learn python for
data science. They're really cool.
The idea of evolution, Darwinian
evolution, it's a really cool, and it's,
it's how we've evolved, right? But in
practice, in practice, we don't see,
um, you know, as good results
as we see with you know,
these with deep learning. But you
know, we might later on we, you know,
who knows.
And I think that there are ideas from
Jeanette genetic algorithms that can be
applied to deep learning.
Remember,
what we're seeing in the real discoveries
that are happening right now is where
we're taking these abstract ideas,
this idea of hierarchy from deep learning.
This idea of an agent of an other,
of reinforcement of trial
and error for reinforcing.
And by combining these ideas,
we're going to get even better results.
So I think genetic algorithms have a
lot of great ideas to give to us. Okay.
And uh, I will, I will definitely
do more videos on genetic,
how returns in the future, how to
communicate with objective c. Uh,
don't use objective c,
use swift,
how to improve because apple
is now maintaining that.
And actually swift is great for
even server side code at this point,
not just mobile apps.
How to improve CV for Google internship.
Mccool I have a video on job interviews
that I'm going to release very soon
either this week or next week.
I already have the footage.
I just need to edit and release that.
How close are we to humans
to solving intelligence?
My best guess is five to 10 years.
Uh,
unless some kind of cataclysmic,
you know,
anything bad happens that prevents that,
the rate of discovery
that's happening right now.
Are there starter videos that
you talked slower in? Uh,
I'm just going to keep talking
slower and slower. Okay. Uh, okay.
So a couple more questions.
Do you think an evolutionary slash genetic
algorithm to create the structure of
a neural network? Absolutely.
I mean, absolutely. They've,
we've seen them creates a
bunch of other things as well.
I don't think I've ever
seen anyone try to do that.
So that's a great project
to try to recreate,
let's say a simple blue
layer before neural networks.
You think genetic algorithms,
that would be a great project.
Okay.
What's 10 years is very optimistic,
but just look at like the paper that
was just released yesterday by deep mine
when they already beat their DQ
network. That is, can be, uh,
generalized to a bunch of different games.
Um,
what else should we learn in
AI ml and d l after ml and DL?
That's really the, the
bleeding edge right now. Um,
but I would say if you want to
go just even further like that,
the real future one shot learning for
specifically probabilistic programming.
Okay. Probabilistic programming or you
could call it Basie and program learning.
It's the same thing.
You have any examples of using a neural
net on random images from the internet?
Uh, yeah. Build a tensorflow
image classifier in five minutes.
Okay.
Okay. How do you keep up with all
the white papers that are released?
Andre Karpati has a great website
called Archive sanity.org.
I've Ar Xib, sn, s a n.
I, t y, Google that and then
a n d. R. E. J. Great. It, I,
that's my tool. Okay. I'm going to answer
two more questions and then we're done.
If it's only five to 10 years,
should I start a computer science degree
next year or should it rule on my own
with you? And did your you Udacity roll
on your own? Anton roll on your own.
Remember to have your get hub full upgrade
projects because get hub is the new
resume.
Okay.
And practice your interviewing skills and
a whole video on that very soon. Okay.
Two more. Okay. So actually
two more questions.
Additional resources for style transfer.
I will link those to those in the
description. Also my last video last week,
the video, cause that's some
great resources in there.
One more question. Okay. What
do you think about the new,
no,
uh,
I want to make it a good question.
What drives you? Shabaam Goop Jab I. Okay.
So what drives me to be totally
honest with driving number one,
one anything is to solve intelligence by
teaching you guys, you know, whatever I,
whatever, I know you guys can help us all
because it's a, it's a shared journey.
We're trying to solve intelligence
so that we can solve everything else.
We have so many problems in the world.
If you've traveled to developing
countries, you see just the,
the scope of problems is
so immense and it is just,
I am very impatient and I want to
solve all these in my lifetime.
I want to see it all sorts
and the best way to do that,
it's to make better and more intelligent
software. It is the best way to do that.
Okay. And that's what
drives me. And also just,
I've always wanted to do great things
and this is a great way to do that.
And also I just, I want to be out
there and I went to, I feel like I,
I feel like I have a responsibility to
read. It's like this internal, like I,
I just feel like I need to
dream big. And we, and, and,
and I went to and see you guys become
leaders as well because you are all the
real leaders of the future. I'm here
to help you guys become leaders. Okay.
So that's what I'm here for and I will,
I will keep going. Oh, keep going.
No matter what happens, I
will just keep going and, oh,
keep going until my last breath. Hopefully
there's no last breath because we saw,
hey, I, and you know, we
had this singularity. Okay.
Is Deep owning a fad? No,
it's not a fad. It's a,
it's, it's a next step in,
in a series of discoveries and I'm
sure the next thing is going to be even
better. But Dave, uh, in a way, it's
not like it's the end goal, right?
There's going to be more accurate,
but it's a part of this
thing about I'm not working
at Twilio. Um, okay. So,
uh, this wonderful time. All right,
so that's all for my questions.
Thanks guys for being here. I have a
video coming up this, uh, on Friday,
like always. And uh, okay, so that's
it for this livestream. Let's see.
Anything else I want to do now? I'll just
say I'll say the rapper next time. Okay.
So love you guys remember to, uh, links
are going to be in the description.
Everything's going to be awesome.
Remember to join our channel. All right,
love you guys. And uh,
thanks for watching.
For now I've got to go drink some coffee
and then transfer the style of the
coffee into my brain and just minimize
a loss between my sleepiness and
wakefulness. So, oh, freestyle. Oh,
someone said freestyle. So I'll do it.
Cause you guys know I love to freestyle.
Um, uh, Prince Albert copied. So,
okay,
I love to drink coffee.
No, no, no, that's,
that's what I want to do it about
machine learning. So, uh, so what's a,
what did we just talked about? We talked
about a style transfer. So style. Okay.
I love to talk about style. I
take my boat, drive down the road,
but now I do it in a spit out bile.
That's not about it's flow. Anyway,
that's it for this time. People
laughing cause I'm trying to freestyle.
It doesn't matter because I'm
trying to go with the Nile River.
You got ancient secrets that the Egyptians
made, but now we got even more men,
bars, bars, bars. Okay. Woo.
Freestyle transfer. Anyway. All right.
Thanks for watching guys.
Okay.